ces journées sont très importantes pour
l'ensemble des praticiens en cardiologie
de la région antilles guyane
parce que c'est des journées
scientifiques où il y à des discussions
sur les dernières avancées en
cardiologie et aussi ses deux occasions
de partage d'expériences avec nos
différents collègues et sur sept
départements en pour homogénéiser nos
pratiques et être au point des dernières
recommandations et aussi être au courant
de tout ce qui se passe actuellement
avec les nouvelles et technologie et
avec tout ce qui est nouveau en
cardiologie
mais aussi dans un monde en mutation où
il ya il ya des adaptations aussi de
législation et un temps pour réglementer
un certain nombre de pratiques et aussi
comme il ya beaucoup de progrès
techniques aussi pour bien et pour pour
bien on va dire établir les cadres dans
lesquels elle s'est posée doit être
utilisé alors quelle est la relation
d'un cardiologue et son patient d'une
manière générale on va dire que permet
tait quand même là où l'audace de
l'expression c'est très souvent une
opération très cordiale parce que le
coeur est un organe est qui qui est
centrale pour l'organisme les patients
ils sont très très attentif aux
différents problèmes qu'ils peuvent
rencontrer dans ce contexte là et ils
viennent à leur rendez vous et nous on
fait tout ce qui tout ce qui est en
notre possibilité pour faire des
consultations de qualité et aussi pour
améliorer et
nos pratiques pour que les gens ils
puissent avoir une santé et voilà qu'ils
soient pour m